هنا في جنوب إنجلترا ، خلف
هذه الأكواخ الشاطئية ، توجد
قرية عائمة عائمة وغريبة
جدًا في بعض الأحيان تطفو أحيانًا وفي أحيان أخرى
تجلس على الوحل بسبب المد ولكن
هذا لا يهم الآن ، لذلك دون
مزيد من اللغط ، دعنا نطلق العنوان  بطاقة
[موسيقى] ،
مرحبًا بكم في مجتمع السبا الصحي
الذي أقيم فيه ، اسمي هاميش
ماكنزي وأنا أنظر إلى نفسي كمُجدد للقوارب ،
هذا المجتمع من المراكب العائمة
يبلغ عدد أفراده حوالي 50 شخصًا يمكنني القول بأمان
أنه لا يوجد اثنان متطابقان إلى حد كبير
يعرضان  شخصية
الأشخاص الذين يعيشون عليها ، لذا دعنا
نتعرف على هاميش ، فلديه سبعة قوارب ، ولديه
ميكروويف كصندوق بريد ، يمكنه فعل ذلك بالمنشار ،
فلديه مجموعة كبيرة
من هيا بنا نترك هناك انتقل هاميش إلى
هنا قبل 32 عامًا بعد  وقعت في
أوقات عصيبة ، وجدت نفسي بلا مأوى
وأتحدث مع صديق ، حيث جلسوا
في الآخر ، ودردشنا حول
القوارب ، وبرز هذا المكان في ذهني
وبعد ثلاثة أسابيع كنت أعيش هنا
، كنت أفكر  ght تمكن قاربي الأول من
التحرك هنا ، لكن الأرض مقابل أجر ضئيل فقط ،
هذا أبعد من ذلك ، هذا هو أنني أعيش
في الفضاء الخارجي على متن قطار ، فهذه
سيارة إسعاف قديمة ومدرب قديم وأعرف كودي
من طائرة جامبو حيث يمكنك
الحصول على  أنف مخروط من طائرة ضخمة في مزرعة
ليست بعيدة من هنا ، لقد كنت بعد مخروط أنف
لفترة من الوقت عادل بما فيه الكفاية
، لا أعتقد أنه أسلوب حياة مجاني بشكل خاص
لمجرد أنني أستطيع أن أبنيها
وأقوم بتصميم ما يعجبني ولدي مبنى
الحفارات لا أخطط للعقاب
الآن ، أعرف ما الذي تفكر فيه لماذا
يوجد على الأرض حافلة أو سيارة خردة على
متن قارب ما سيبدو عليه ، قال
إنها فكرة ممتعة تمامًا أو استخدم
عجلات الجرارات لجعل Windows مثاليًا
هل تعتقد أن كل هذه الأفكار
تتأرجح في عقلك ، فأنا لا
أرسم أي شيء لطيف حقًا وأحب هنا ، هل أنت من
المواد الثانوية أعتقد أن هناك حياة
في كائنات غير حية ، لقد عاشوا
حياة واحدة وأنت فقط تغير
الغرض من خلال أن تصبح  منزل عائم يعيد استخدام
الأشياء ويعطيها كـ  الحياة الاقتصادية
لأنها تولد طاقتها الخاصة
وكان هذا قاربًا سريعًا للمساحات التي
تنشئها باستخدام أشكال مختلفة
عندما تبدأ في أن تصبح ممتعة ، الكثير منها
يبدأ في تصميم نفسه بعد الدفء
لأن هذه الأشياء تتلاءم معًا بشكل
جيد جدًا ويمكنني بناء كل ما
يمكنني تخيله  كان القيد الوحيد على أسلوبي في
البناء هو قدرتي